اليوم امل القضاء في قضيه الوثائق السريه
والسلطات جاهزه للتعامل مع اي حدود
واحتجاجات
يصف الهجوم المضاد بالصعب وتساؤلات حول
جدول دعم الغربيه
اصابه 22 عسكريا امريكيا في حادث لمروحيه
في سوريا والقياده المركزيه في رصد نيران
المعاديه
[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره الاخباريه من العربيه يمثل رئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب اليوم امام
محكمه فيدراليه في ميامي على خلفيه قضايا
او قضيه الوثائق السريه يواجه ترامب 37
تهمه من بينها الاحتفاظ غير القانوني
بمعلومات تتعلق بالامن القومي وعرقلت
العداله وشهاده الزور
في الاثناء كاد عمده مدينه ميامي فرانسيس
سواريز جاهزيه الشرطه للتعامل مع الحشود
والاحتجاجات الكبيره
نؤمن بالدستور ونؤمن انه من حق الناس
التعبير عن ارائهم لكننا نؤمن ايضا
بالنظام ونامل ان تكون التظاهرات مسالمه
وندعو الناس الذين سيتظاهرون الى ان
يكونوا مسالمين ونشجعهم على ذلك سنؤمن
القوات اللازمه للحفاظ على السلامه كما
اننا ننوه بان منطقه وسط المدينه ستشهد
حركه مروريه اضافيه لذلك على السكان فيها
الاستعداد لذلك
منذ وقت الاعلان عن الاحتجاجات ونحن نحضر
لها من اجل الحفاظ على امن وسلامه المدينه
وكل زائريها نعمل مع شركائنا الفدراليين
للحفاظ على النظام والقانون كما نحرص على
حقوق الجميع في التعبير عن نفسهم
فيما تتجه الانظار الى ميامي حيث سيمثل
الرئيس السابق ضمن ترامب امام محكمه فيها
يعمل الاخير على اظهار المواجهه مع خصومه
وكانها مع الشيوعيين واليسريين
والماركسيين على حد وصفه وصف ترامب جاء في
اعلان له على سوشيال حيث اوضح انه يتحضر
للتوجه الى دورال في ميامي مؤكدا على
ضروره البقاء مع انصاره اقوياء وهزيمه
هؤلاء الخصومه الذين اتهمهم بتدمير
الولايات المتحده بشكل ممنهج
يريد ان يظهر وكانه يواجه اعداء امريكا
المحاكمه تاتي من هؤلاء الشيوعيين او
الماركسيين لذا فهو يحاول تصوير المدعين
ليس كاعداء الله فحسب بل اعداء للولايات
المتحده يعتقد انه وامريكا واحد
ومع تصاعد الجدل بين انصار ترامب وخصومه
بعد توجيه لائحه اتهام من 37 تهمه للرئيس
السابق تتزايد مخاوف حدوث اعمال عنف سياسي
خاصه بعد تغريده النائب الجمهوري المؤيد
له انديبز التي قال فيها ان البلاد وصلت
الى مرحله الحرب
انه بالتاكيد شيء مقلق عندما يتصاعد خطاب
هؤلاء السياسيين اكثر فاكثر كما تسمع ايضا
مالكي الاسلحه وموقفهم ولا يساعد هذا في
خفض التصعيد والجمهوريين بحاجه الى اعتبار
ان كلماتهم قد تكون خطيره اذا راينا عنفا
سياسيا في الايام المقبله
في غضون ذلك يصر ترامب رغم توجيه لائحه
الاتهامات الفيدراليه له على اكمال حملته
للحصول على ترشيح الحزب الجمهوري ومنددا
بما يصفه بحمله الاضطهاد ضده وتسييس وزاره
العدل للقضاء حسين الطاوضه العربيه واشنطن
[موسيقى]
وصف الرئيس الاوكراني بول سكيل القتال
والهجوم المضاد بالصعب لكنه يمضي قدما اكد
زيلنسكي لاستعاده السيطره على سبع بلدات
اوكرانيه من القوات الروسيه على الطرف
الاخر نفت موسكو نجاح الهجوم المضاد
الاوكراني في تحقيق اي تقدم على ارض
الميدان قالت روسيا ان الهجوم المضاد فشل
حتى الان ونشرت صورا لمركبات ودبابات
قتاليه امريكيه والمانيه مدمره قامت روسيا
ببنايه تحصينات دفاعيه متراميه الاطراف
لتصدي لهجوم القوات الاوكرانيه
ومع اعلان كياف عن استعاده قرى في هجومها
المضاد وصفت صحيفه ورث تلك المكاسب
الصغيره مقارنه مع حجم الدعم الغربي
لاوكرانيا الاشهر الماضيه
تكتمت كييف على انطلاقه هجومها المضاد لكن
ملامحه كانت واضحه منذ ايام
25 معركه تحدث عنها الجيش الاوكراني
بالقرب من بخموت شرقي البلاد وجنوبا
بالقرب من افديفكا ومارينكا في دونسك وقرب
بيلوريفيكا في منطقه لوغانسك وفقرز
ميدانيا حققت القوات الاوكرانيه مكاسب في
المرحله الاولى من الهجوم المضاده
مكاسب وصفتها صحيفه وول ستريت جونل
الامريكيه بالصغيره مقارنه بحجم الاستعداد
وتسليح الغربي طيله الاشهر الماضيه
بحسب الصحيفه فان الهجمات الاولى كانت
مكلفه حيث دمرت مركبات قتال ودبابات اضافه
الى تخلي القوات الاوكرانيه عن ناقله جندن
ومركبه قتاليه لكن تمت التفوق لاسلحه
القوات الاوكرانيه الغربيه على الروسيه
خصوصا في الهجمات والعمليات الليليه
فالاوكرانيون اختاروا الهجوم ليلا لتقليل
فعاليات القوات الجويه الروسيه وتجنب
هجمات المسيرات وفق تقرير لصحيفه
الليبراسيون الفرنسيه غير ان المعادله
تتغير نهارا فتنكشف تحركات الاوكران
انكشاف مكن الروس من تحقيق ضربات مباشره
لدبابات ومركبات المانيه وامريكيه الصنع
استخدمتها القوات الاوكرانيه
اعترفت بذلك لكنها قللت من حجم خسائرها
خسائر دفعت بيكييف للطلب من المانيا زياده
عدد الدبابات ليوبارد الى ثلاثه اضعاف
اضافه الى مركبات قتاليه وصواريخ كروز
بعيده المدى
احتضن قصر الاليزي في باريس اليوم قمه
ثلاثيه ضمه
الى الجانب المستشار الالماني حيث ناقشت
وفق بيان الاليزي التنسيق الاوروبيه
الضروري حول المساعده العسكريه التي ستقدم
لاوكرانيا لتمكينها من تنفيذ هجومها
المضاد ناقش المجتمعون هنا الضمانات
الامنيه الطويله المدى التي يجب برايهم ان
تعطى لاوكرانيا لضمان سيادتها
على ضروره مواصله ارسال الاسلحه الى كييف
لكن الرئيس الفرنسي انفرد بموقف لافت
عندما حدد هدف السلاح المرسل الى
الاوكرانيين وهو الدفاع عن اراضيهم فقط
ولا يجب ان يستخدم هذا السلاح باي حال من
الاحوال لمهاجمه روسيا كما قال ماكرون
حسين قنيبر للعربيه والحدث من قصر
الاليزيه باريس
الحرب العسكريه في اوكرانيا توازيها حروب
اخرى تاخذ اشكالا مختلفه بين روسيا
والمعسكر الغربي فاستعراض القوه العسكريه
تحول في حد ذاته الى صراع يطمح كل طرف في
العتبات تفوقه فيه حيث الناتو والحليب
الاول في حربها ضد موسكو اطلق اضخم
مناورات جويه في تاريخه والتي تحمل اسم
23 مناورات تستضيفها المانيا وتستمر حتى
الثالث والعشرين من شهر يونيو
القوات الجويه الالمانيه قال ان مناوره
اير ديفاندر 2023 خط خطه لتنفيذها منذ
فتره طويله اضاف انها تهدف لاظهار القدره
الدفاعيه لهذا التحالف
من خلال المناوره نظهر ونثبت ونستعرض
القدره الدفاعيه لهذا التحالف التدريب
اشاره لنا في المقام الاول اعضاء النيتو
هم من يشاركون في هذا التمرين الذي تقوده
المانيا ونظهر اننا قادرون على الدفاع عن
هذا البلد وهذا التحالف
[موسيقى]
قالت مصادره بمجلس السياده السوداني ان
الجنرال عبد الفتاح البرهان لم يوافق على
مقترحات افريقيه بشان عقد لقاء مع احمد
كان رئيس الكيني قد تعهد الاثنين بترتيب
لقاء يجمع بين الجنرلين المتحاربين في
السودان في مسعى لانهاء الازمه التي تعصف
بالبلاد بعد فشل العديد من الاتفاقات وقف
اطلاق النار وفق ما اعلنت الرئاسات
الكينيه
[موسيقى]
افاد المتحدث باسم الامم المتحده ستيفان
دو جاري بان مبعوثه الامين العام فولكر
بيرسي يعمل من نيروبي عاصمه كينيا على
الملف السوداني على المتحدث من الامم
المتحده مستمره في النقاش مع السلطات
السودانيه حول عده قضايا مشيرا لوجود 42
الف شخص عالقونا في جزيره توتي بالخرطوم
ليحصلون على الرعايه الصحيه والخدمات
الاساسيه اشارت في تصريحاته لوصول مساعدات
انسانيه لنحو مليونير شخص خلال الاسابيع
الثلاثه الماضيه شدد المتحدث باسم الامم
المتحده على ضروره تامين ممر امن لتوزيع
مواد الاغا
ثه كان رئيس مفوضيه الاتحاد الافريقي موسى
فكي حذر من اندلاع حرب اهليه في السودان
وانتشار الفوضى في حال لم تنتهي الحرب قال
في كلمه له خلال انعقاد مؤتمر الايجاد ان
الاتحاد الافريقي يشجعه على حوار وطني
شامل يقوده سودانيون
الازمه العميقه والعنفه في السودان
والتهديدات الخطيره التي تمثلها لوجود هذه
البلاد والمنطقه كلها واضحه جدا كل
التحليلات تتفق على ان هذه الحرب في حال
لم تتوقف ستفضي لاندلاع حرب اهليه وستعم
الفوضى كما انها ستؤدد انهيار الدوله
بالكامل الاليه الثلاثيه التزمت بتوفير
الدعم للسودان لوقف الحرب وتوفير
المساعدات الانسانيه لكل من يحتاج اليها
كما تلتزم بمساعده السودانيين الى الذهاب
نحو حوار وطني شامل ومخطط يقوده
السودانيون انفسهم بعيدا عن اي تاثيرات
خارجيه مع انقطاع الطرق القوميه بين
الولايات والعاصمه الخرطوم بسبب الحرب
تزدهر تجارته الحدوديه لسد النقص في السلع
الضروريه ففي دارفور غربيه سودان تصل
يوميا عشرات سيارات الى ولايه شرق دارفور
قادمه من دوله جنوب السودان تحمل الكثير
من السلع الاساسيه توزع على عدد من مدن
الاقليم الان طريق الجنوب مخفف لنا 99% من
المواد الغذائيه 99% يعني الان معتمدين
على جنوب السودان
معتمدين عليه اعتماد ذاتي وحلا لشو حلوه
قود يدخل البنزين القادم لاوغندا كسلعه
مؤقته هنا اضافه الى ما يصل من دوله ليبيا
لكنها واجس الخوف تسيطر على سائق الشاحنات
بسبب انعدام الامن والتفلتات
يعني من نجد اخواننا التجار واخواننا في
الغرفه التجاريه برضو يساعدونا نحن
كمواطنين في هذه المنطقه في بضائع برضو
مخزنه يعني الناس اتعمل باسعار شويه فيها
هدوء بالرغم انه لكن الان البلد فيها
بضاعه من عدمه البضاعه عشان مثلا الاسعار
تكون زائده للجن ونحن بحث دائم هنا في
اقليم دارفور يهدف الى سد الحاجه عبر ما
يتدفق من سلع الحدوديه موارد تعول عليها
السلطات المحليه وتعمل على تغنينها
واستدامتها
تظل التجاره الحدوديه باقليم دارفور هي
حلا للعديد من السلع الاساسيه في فصل
الصيف هذا لكن يظل التحدي قائما في فصل
الخريف الذي اقترب الان صالح ابو علامه
لقناته العربيه والحدث اقليم دارفور غربيه
السودان
مستمره وفيها
الولايات المتحده تتهم الصين بمحاوله
تعطيل البنيه التحتيه الحيويه لامريكا
اهلا بكم من جديد كشفت القياده المركزيه
الامريكيه عن اصابه 22 الجنديا في حادث
طائره مروحيه في سوريا لاحد الماضي بيان
القياده المركزيه
بين الجنود نفا بيان القياده رصد اي نيران
معاديه قبل الحادث الذي تم فتح تحقيقا
لمعرفه اسبابه
اتهامات الولايات المتحده الصين بمحاوله
تعطيل البنيه التحتيه الحيويه في حال حدوث
صراع بين الجانبين في تصريحات في معهد في
واشنطن قالت رئيسه وكاله الامن الالكتروني
وامن البنيه التحتيه الامريكيه انبكين
توجه استثمارات ضخمه لتعزيز القدره على
تخريب البنيه التحتيه الامريكيه وقالت
تعتقد ان هذا هو التهديد الحقيقي الذي
نحتاج الى الاستعداد له والتركيز عليه
وتطوير قدره على مجابهته
رفض جونكر بالمتحدث باسم مجلس الامن
القومي في البيت الابيض تاكيدا ما تناولته
تقارير صحفيه حول اتفاق مؤكد مؤقت مع
ايران اكد كيربي في رده على السؤال
لمراسله العربيه ان الولايات المتحده
واسرائيل تتشاوران حول ملف ايران النووي
بشكل خفيف مشيرا الى ان نشاطها المزعزع
للاستقرار يتجاوز الكثير من المحاور على
حد قوله
نحن نتشاور مع اسرائيل في واقع الامر كما
تعلمين كان منسق الشرق الاوسط في المنطقه
منذ وقت قصير وعقد اجتماعات مع نظرائه
الاسرائيليين نتشاور معهم عن كثب لدينا
فكره مشتركه عن استمرار السلوك المزعزع
للاستقرار والتهديدات القادمه من ايران في
المنطقه مره اخرى لن اؤكد التقارير
الصحفيه حول وجود صفقات من عدمها نحن نركز
على النشاط الايراني المزعزع للاستقرار
وهو يتجاوز الكثير من المحاور ليس فقط في
الطموحات النوويه ولكن بزياده القدرات
الصاروخيه والعلاقه الدفاعيه المزدهره مع
روسيا ودعمها في اوكرانيا ومضايقه الشحن
البحري لدعم الشبكات الارهابيه في المنطقه
الاتفاق النووي الايراني ابرم في الرابع
عشر من يوليو 2015 في فيينا توصلت ايران
وامريكا وبريطانيا وفرنسا وروسيا والصين
والمانيا الاتفاقن عرف باسم خطه العمل
الشامل المشتركه بموجبه باتت تخضع انشطه
ايران النوويه لبرنامج الرقابه وتفتيش
تابع للوكاله الذريه
الثامن من مايو 2018 اعلان الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب انسحاب
بلاده احاديا من الاتفاق وفرض عقوبات على
ايران
مطالب ايران للعوده الى الاتفاق النووي
ضمانات امريكيه بعدم انسحاب اي رئيس
مستقبلا من الصفقه
تخلل وكاله الذريه عن تحقيق مدته ثلاث
سنوات في اليورانيوم المخصب في منشات
ايرانيه مختلفه
من جهه اخرى اكدت الخارجيه الايرانيه ان
اي اتفاق سيتم التوصل اليه بشان الملف
النووي سيحمي مصالح ايران ويراعي الخطوط
الحمراء قال المتحدث باسم الخارجيه
الايرانيه ناصر كنعاني نيران لا تجري اي
مباحثات او لا تجري اي مباحثات لابرام
اتفاق النووي مؤقت او جديد وان اي تفاوض
يجب ان يكون على اساس اتفاق 2015
لن نقبل باتفاق مؤقت لقد تبادلنا الرسائل
مع الاطراف المتفاوضه عبر سلطنه عمان لا
نوافق على اي مفاوضات لابرام اتفاق مؤقت
يحل محل الاتفاق النووي السابق نحن نعتبر
هذه المزاعم تكهنات اعلاميه او انباء تروج
لها اطراف بدوافع سياسيه او لتعكير مسار
عمليه المفاوضات الحاليه
[موسيقى]
الحكومه اللبنانيه تلوح بقطع الكهرباء عن
مخيمات اللاجئين تاكيدا جاء على اللسان او
تاكيد جاء على اللسان وزير الطاقه والمياه
وليد فياض الذي اكد ضروره دفع تكلفه
استهلاك اللاجئين الفلسطينيين والسوريين
من الكهرباء في البلاد وزير والطاقه
اللبنانيه في تصريحاته لامكانيه قطع
الكهرباء عن المخيمات في حال عدم السداد
هنا لازم ندفع حق الكهرباء لانه هذه
الكهرباء اللي عم تتامل اليوم عم تتامل
الى كلفه ويجب ان تغطى ان كان الانتاج او
التشغيل او التوزيع او الصيانه او
المعاشات كله هيدا لازم يتغطوا ويتغطى
وطبعا مش مطلوب من اللبنانيين انه يغطوا
كلفه استهلاك
الاخوان السوريين والفلسطينيين كل واحد
بده يخطي كلفه استهلاكه
نبقى في لبنان حيث لا يتوقع الكثير من
جلسات الاربعاء الانتخابيه لكنها المره
الاولى التي يتواجه فيها مرشحان واحد
ومجتمعت عليه المعارضه ومعها التيار
الوطني الحر بمواجهه مرشح الثنائي الشيعي
رغم هدوء ساحه المجلس النيابي الا ان
المشاورات لم تتوقف هنا منذ ايام
على مدخله يقفون ايبان اساسيان من نواب
التغيير الذين تاخروا في حسم موقفهم من
تسميه وزير المال السابق جهاد ازعور كمرشح
لرئاسه الجمهوريه
سته نواب وقفوا مترددين في الخانه
الرماديه بالتاكيد لا يريدون سليمان
فرنجيه رئيسا لكنهم وبخلاف غيرهم من
التغيريين الذين تبعثروا بين ازور وزياد
بارود لم يحسموا خيارهم على فرضيه ان
الزعور سبق وشغل منصب وزير الماليه
ما اعلنوا موقف لانه عندهم قراءه يعني
مختلفه للواقع القائم اليوم عم يتشاوروا
بشكل متواصل لا يقدروا يوصلوا لموقف مشترك
وهذا بعتقد شيء طبيعي بظل حساسيه الموقف
وحساسيه
اللحظه السياسيه اللي نحن فيها وتقارب
الاصوات فاضروري نحن نكون عم ندرس
خياراتنا بشكل كثير دقيق واتجاهنا اللي
هنصوت فيه للمره الاولى وبعد تجميد منصبه
في صندوق النقد الدولي اصدر مرشح المعارضه
والتيار الوطني الحر جهاد ازعور بيانا
متوجها فيه الى ناخبيه قدم نفسه كابن
التجربه اللبنانيه نافيا ان يكون مرشح كحد
كما يحلو للثنائي الشيعي وصفه
بيان وزعور اتى بعد كلمه رئاسيه القاها
مرشح الثنائي سليمان فرنجيه وصف خلالها
منافسه بابن المنظومه حزب الله لا ينظر
الى الامر من الزاويه المحلي البحته هناك
ما يحصل بالاقليم المفاوضات الايرانيه
الامريكيه حول ملف النووي مجددا اتفاق
باكين وغيره من التطورات التي شهدها هذا
الاقليم حزب الله ينتظر تسويه اقليميه عبر
البوابه الايرانيه تحديدا لكي يشرع باتجاه
انتخاب رئيس للجمهوريه من هنا جلسه
الاربعاء هي جلسه تصعيد اعلامي معركه
تحت ستشكل احراجا لمرشح الثنائي في حال لم
يجاري مرشح المعارضه بتعداد يلامس الستين
صوتا تتجه الانظار ليوم الاربعاء جلسه لن
تكون حاسمه في حرب الانتخابات الرئاسيه
لكن دلالاتها بالتاكيد ستعيد خلط اوراق
كافه الكتل السياسيه غنوه يتيم العربيه
بيروت
حضرت نقابه عماليه في لبنان من ازمه تلوح
في الافق بعدما اعلنت وزاره الماليه
الاسبوع الماضي عن عدم قدرته على دفع
رواتب موظفي الدوله عن شهر يونيو بحسب
البيان ابدى رئيس الاتحاد العمالي العام
بشار الاسمر مخاوفه من خطوره عدم صرف
رواتب الموظفين البالغ عددهم نحو 300 الف
موظف بين مدنيين وعسكريين ومتقاعدين وذلك
بسبب عدم تامين الاعتمادات الماليه يذكر
ان وزير الماليه لا يستطيع استخدام
احتياطي الموازنه الا بالعوده الى مجلس
النواب لاقرار مشروع قانون يسمح له بفتح
اعتمادات جديده
قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انطوني
بلينكل انه يود ان تقدم تونس خطه اصلاح
معدله للصندوق النقد الدولي اضافينه من
الواضح ان تونس بحاجه الى مزيد من
المساعده اذا كانت تريد تجنبا انهيار
اقتصادي
اجتاح الدخان وغرب كندا مع اندلاع حرائق
الغابات مره اخرى في اقليم البرتا بينما
اخمد رجال الاطفاء في كبك بعضا من اسوا
حرائق الموسم المبكره وهو ما سمح للالاف
ممن تم اجلاؤهم بالعوده الى ديارهم تشهد
كندا اسوء موسم حرائق غابات على الاطلاق
اذا تتنيران على نحو ثمانيه واربعين الف
كيلو متر مربع وفقا للمركز الكندي لمكافحه
حريق الغابات بلغ عدد الحرائق المشتعله
يوم الاثنين نحو
449 حريقا في جميع انحاء كندا منها 219
حريقا خارج نطاق السيطره
في نهايه نشره تذكيرا بابرز العناوين
ترامب يمثل اليوم امام القضاء في قضيه
الوثائق السريه والسلطه الجاهزه للتعامل
مع اي حدود واحتجاجات
ذا لانسكي يصف الهجوم المضاد بالصعب
وتساؤلات حول جدوى دعم الغربي لكياف
اصابه 22 عسكريين امريكيا في حادث مروحيه
في سوريا والقياده المركزيه في رصد نيران
معاديه
في امان الله
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات